all right bearded and Weirdos
let's get into it
[Music]
hello folks I want to talk about or
actually rather two one topic uh
otherwise known as one Topic at a time
otherwise known as OT except also not
really this isn't really about him the
he is just the channel and the
personality I'm going to filter this
discussion through uh why him
he's just the Creator who I think
articulated most clearly the thing that
I wish to talk about and also minor side
thing I have a little bit of hope that
maybe this will eventually pass on to
him and maybe he will hear what it is I
am about to say and take it into
consideration going forward because to
be very clear I like one topic I
discovered his channel fairly recently
when doing uh stuff for the Illuminati
video actually at that point I just
caught his name in passing I didn't
focus on him when I did that video but
his name came up in the comments a lot
alongside the word wholesome and I did
look into his stuff
and yeah wholesome's a real good word
he's actually become one of my most
recent youTube binges but that was where
I noticed the thing that I want to talk
about now before I get into this I want
to be really clear this is not intended
as a call out I'm not mad at OT I'm not
trying to get anybody against him it's
just that he happens to articulate
something that I think is a problem and
I don't think he intends for it to be a
problem and I'm hoping to address it and
again his is not the only Channel this
impacts this actually impacts a lot and
if you are a regular here on this
channel this might even be something
you've heard me talk about before but I
don't have that bigger reach and I'm
gonna take another swing at this topic
while getting into the overall idea
deeper than I did when I talked about it
before don't worry I will explain all
this so one Topic at a time if you
aren't aware does basically a reaction
Channel he's probably best known for
reacting to various subreddits and memes
and giving his thoughts and he does a
ton of incredibly positive content
oftentimes very queer positive very
trans positive and even when he comes
across something that is very clearly
coming from a place to hate the general
um feeling that he expresses is that
well I hope they can get to a better
place honestly he's a heck of a lot more
wholesome and idealistic than I am or
ever could or would or will be and I
honestly admire him for that there is
however one thing that I've seen come up
a couple of times on his channel that he
has expressed that I think has some
problems with it and it has to do with
the running of
anti-queer ads on his channel things
like what is a Woman by Matt Walsh
whatever that latest monstrosity the
epoch times is pushing any number of
various things from prageru Etc et
cetera et cetera this is a fairly long
running problem if you follow queer
creators you've probably seen periods
where they are bombarded with these
kinds of ads running on their Channel
and he is aware of this I know because
he addressed it now I actually let him
speak directly to give his position that
I'm now going to address once he says it
so
me trying to watch a pro trans video
YouTube ads mad Walsh documentary what
is a woman what is a woman oh God damn
it that's like here yeah it happens a
lot I can't really control that but but
on the plus side at least they're
wasting their money
propaganda is clearly not cut for us
okay so there's a couple of things here
there's two main things one is a factual
inaccuracy which I think is completely
unintended by his part there's something
that I very strongly believe he is not
aware of because most creators aren't so
there's one thing that is just factually
untrue and then there is kind of the
philosophical underpinnings and I want
to deal with both but we're going to
deal with the factual inaccuracy first
because it's easiest he says there's not
much that he can do about that
that is not true you can in fact prevent
certain ads from running on your channel
now I expect
OT doesn't know this most creators don't
know this YouTube and Google do not
advertise the fact that you can do this
in fact you cannot even do this
from your YouTube Studio dashboard you
have to do this through AdSense which
the vast majority of YouTubers I suspect
have not touched their AdSense account
since they set it up as part of their
requirements for getting monetized but
once it's set up nobody goes back to
this thing it's archaic it's clunky and
you do everything from your dashboard
not this now I actually did an entire
video detailing step-by-step
instructions for how to not only block
certain categories of ads such as for
example on this channel I don't allow
the running of religious ads political
ads gambling ads or weight loss ads so
you can block entire categories but the
thing is when you're trying to prevent
ads from things like the daily wire or
the epoch times or prageru that can be
harder to categorize these are
frequently highly political ads but they
also won't classify them as political
because they're not endorsing a
candidate they will classify them under
education because something like what is
a woman is theoretically a documentary
or any number of things it's not like
you can just block a category called
hateful ads because no one's going to
mark their ad as being hateful
what you can do is you can block ads
from specific websites because you may
notice when an ad runs especially in the
pre-roll when the ad runs then under the
video they'll basically be a little
quick link to take you to it whatever
that link takes you to whatever other
site that takes you to
that is a website that you can block
from running ads on your channel now
this is an imprecise archaic and pain in
the ass process it's not designed to be
user friendly and more to the point it's
something you have to continually update
because while I have had say the daily
wire The Babylon B the epoch times
Etc a whole bunch of these places
blocked for some time often when
something like say what is a woman gets
made it will have its own bespoke web
domain created and then you have to
block that specifically because even
though ultimately it all goes back to
the Daily wire that's not the website
that the ad is technically being bought
by so you have to be prepared to update
this it's a pain in the butt but you can
do it you can actually stop these ads
from being run on your Channel
you can start them as categories in some
cases and you can stop specific ones
from specific people
it's a pain
it's a bad system and as I said YouTube
honestly doesn't want people to be able
to do this because if more people had
awareness of the degree of control they
had over what ads can run
then Those ads that YouTube is trying to
sell potentially become less valuable
like imagine the damage if several
thousand creators of size all blocked
ads from a specific person
well guess what
YouTube is not going to be able to
charge as much for ad space because it's
not going to run in nearly as many
places
and whether it has to do with that
specific person or not if in general it
was better known and better used
YouTube would probably not be able to
charge what it does because there'd be a
higher chance of just not being able to
run that ad even though they paid for it
so that is the first thing and while I'm
going to get to sort of the
philosophical underpinnings of what OT
said after that the idea of they're
wasting their money and this propaganda
is wasted on my audience I do believe
and suspect that that is not a belief
that he holds in a vacuum that is
probably a belief and a position that is
brought on by circumstance and basically
trying to find the silver lining because
when you are in a situation where you
believe that you can't do anything like
this is me assuming that he just didn't
know
and was not aware
so from that position if you assume
there's nothing you can do about the ads
then yeah you're going to look for the
silver lining the Silver Lining is
at least some money is getting thrown in
the direction of the queer creators that
these ads are running on because
understand these ads are specifically
being run on these kinds of content when
people buy ads they can say what kind of
videos they want their ads to run on so
the fact that these show up in front of
queer ads is a very deliberate thing but
I understand how if you think you can't
stop that you would come to the
conclusion of well at least it's a
little money and it's probably wasted on
my audience so while I'm going to be
going at and pulling apart that stance
as if it was sincerely held I'm not sure
that that is a sincerely held belief by
OT so much it is as it was a trying to
find the one positive that could be had
out of thinking I can't get rid of these
ads because honestly trying to find the
silver lining is probably healthy it's
how you stop from slipping into total
doomerism
so even though I'm about to talk about
this as a uh more self-contained in a
vacuum philosophical notion
understand that I suspect if by any
chance this video ever gets in front of
OT
that upon finding out that he can block
the ads he just will
but on the off chance that he doesn't or
that anyone else is watching this and
wants to understand why
even if you more firmly believe that
well it's just money for the channel
anyway what's the problem there are
problems
there is damage
because I have seen this said by other
creators I've seen this show up as an
argument in my own comment section
and there are a couple of problems with
it
the first stems from a misunderstanding
of why the ads are being run there
because the position that OT takes the
idea of they're wasting their money and
my audience won't be impacted by this
propaganda comes from a misplaced belief
that the ad is intended to change the
mind of your regular audience
it's not
it's not even really meant for your
regular audience except it kind of is
but not in the way that you think
there are a couple of main things that
this ad is intended to do before I get
to those I want to reiterate this has
been going on for a while I figured out
how to block these kinds of ads
five years ago or so when I first
started getting bombarded with them not
even on this channel but on one of my
other ones
and I figured out how to do this
so these sites have been doing this for
a long time this is not a new strategy
from them and they continue to do it
because they believe it accomplishes the
two things that they want it to which
again I'll get to in a minute
the thing you need to remember when
dealing with this kind of bigotry with
this kind of far-right Notions
it is
hazardous
to assume that they are idiots now don't
get me wrong they're frequently very
stupid either willfully or legitimately
in terms of not listening to science not
paying attention to experts ignoring the
data like they are very much stupid but
what you should never assume is that
they are tactically stupid
don't assume that their techniques and
tactics
don't have some purpose
or don't work
so what is the Tactical purpose of
running an ad like for something like
what is a woman in front of a channel
like OT or any other queer focused or
queer supportive Channel
well the first is it's not fully
intended for the regular audience
because you can look at the size of ot's
channel it's over a million
that's a lot of roommates
that's a lot of people and it's been
growing which means new people are
coming yes you have your regular
audience who is coming to you on a
regular basis knows your stuff but
you're also getting new people
and it's those new people that these ads
are first meant for
there's another use for them as well but
we'll come back to that
because there are people out there
who don't have
queer or trans or Ally focused people in
their life
and who aren't hearing from people they
know personally the arguments against
the bigotry the bigotry they've probably
heard because it's driving most of the
conversation in the discourse and in
news coverage and in legislature and all
that
so if they are coming
looking for more queer positive spaces
going okay what is the other side like
I'm trying to understand
the first thing they see
is an ad from people who hate us
it's an interception
so that someone who is not yet fully on
our side but who maybe could be
persuaded either way is looking for more
information
before they can hear our stories told by
us or by our allies who understand us
they first hear from the bigots they
first hear somebody who talks about us
as if we're dangerous as if we're
predatory as if we're crazy
and it primes them to take an
adversarial position against the actual
video they're about to see
and it may or may not work it's hard to
know numbers on any of this it's a
strategy trying to track it is difficult
but it's not zero whatever the number is
of people that are being intercepted
and either having their acceptance of
what the actual video content is
dampened or just bouncing off it when
they think oh well this is this is the
exact kind of crazy thing that ad was
told me about forget this
I don't know what those numbers are but
it's not zero
but then
there's the impact on your actual
regular audience
on your queer and queer positive
audience
because while these ads do not
persuade them against their current
beliefs of support and acceptance and
love
it's not meant to
it's harassment by way of an
advertisement
your regular audience comes to you
for safety
and for comfort and for reassurance and
for support and before they can get that
they get an ad
that reminds them that there are people
out there who hate them
and that serves a harassment purpose
it serves a purpose because
it invades the spaces where we think
we're safe
it serves a purpose
because when we try and go to find our
comfort
we can't do it
without
them yelling at us first
it's like going to a support group or
just a community center for queer people
and having to walk past a bunch of
protesters yelling that you're going to
go to hell or that you're grooming kids
they're not yelling at you because they
think they're going to change who you
are they're yelling at you so that you
never feel comfortable you never feel
safe
they want us to think they are the
majority and one of the ways they
accomplish that is by never letting us
have peace
by at every opportunity getting in our
face and reminding us
that they hate us
that is why it can feel so oppressive
despite the actual statistical reality
which is that these people are an insane
minority
but they're very loud
and they're not only loud they are
pervasive and they show up everywhere
they possibly can
and if you don't block their ads and
again I understand
OT and others in his position may not
have realized they could do this but if
you know when you don't
you are giving them access to harass
your audience
and that's not good for them
and whatever tiny pittance of pennies
you might make
I don't think the harm done to your
audience coming to you for support
is worth any amount of money
we don't want their money
we don't want them
to pry and buy their way onto our
platforms
to harass our community
and that is why anyone
who has a YouTube channel that is
monetized
if you're hearing this whether you're OT
or anybody else I don't have that much
hope that
OT will ever see this but if you're
seeing this and you've gotten to the end
I hope
that you will block these ads from being
able to run I will put a link in the
description of the video
to the video that I did earlier that
goes through step by step how to do this
why did I focus on OT
it's slightly clickbaity I won't lie
but as I said I've talked about this
before and not a lot of eyes got on it
and I think it could be really useful
information
if more people knew
if bigger platforms new
and
it's just my hope
that this can
spread further than the last time I
talked about it
so
thank you
for listening
whoever it may be who got through to the
end
and
there's all the usual stuff I do this as
a living so there's a patreon like share
subscribe comments help blah blah blah
blah blah algorithm it doesn't like me
but
the reason I'm making this
is what I say at the end of every video
because I want to protect my audience
and I hope this reaches other creators
who want to do the same
because you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council
I am just running the meetings and until
next time this Council
is adjourned
roll that outro
[Music]
and now my thanks my patreon supporters
to make this possible including Robin
Moore Zubin look fulla to rock the thing
that goes doink in the anime Ruth Oliver
B solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen t love
Auntie Kate 808 bernabi likes the poodle
Robin Powell Tracy scrabot angry Casper
Adam RDL Taylor Dave Hall Shayla gourlay
and Rosalind Bennett
you can get uh my bad I get all the
names right and then I can't talk if you
want to hear me stumble over my tongue
after saying your name it's in the
rewards here on the patreon
[Music]
thank you